[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day we're
going to talk about a mysterious photo
of Rihanna and Donald Glover that is
going around as well as the tip the bill
challenge but first check out this video
from Twitter user speedy shad he
videotaped his television and there's
this crazy glitch they're lining up line
of scrimmage so far so good
teleportation I think speedy shad is
going to keep the touchdown
[Laughter]
I watched just four times and I did not
understand I mean it's a fake game this
was from Twitter user Andrew Luck fu
Tour and check this out he's videotaping
his TV he's playing a little mad are
these glitches fun do they make the game
kind of funny or is it like hey Madden
get your together I paid 50 bucks
for this I don't get these games
vendetta against the NFL as I previously
nice comments good thing this isn't the
NFL it's a fake game these things matter
they need to get their together
especially because I'm still sour about
how in Madden 2008 my buddy John would
run the same play over and over and over
again and it would always score and I'd
say stop running that can play keep
doing it and then I throw the controller
and then we wouldn't speak for about an
hour and then we'd play again and it
would happen all over again and his mom
would bring us little bacon sandwiches
and pizza I know it's great yeah but
they need if you're gonna be a game that
is about a sport make a fair but isn't
part of the fun like
like I remember in Madden 98 back when
we're just seeing 30 years old
Pinsir play that you could do that if it
was one defensive play that you could
always get a sack because you didn't
whine up far and then yes he teleported
from one into the field
strategically moving one player back it
gets it gets pretty fun it turns like a
game of Risk you know what I mean just
rolling the dice is he gonna teleport is
he not gonna teleport is Jesus Christ
coming back on the game got another
story there's this mysterious photo
going around of Donald Glover and
Rihanna Ainslie can you blow that up for
us
everyone's going wild it's unclear where
this photo came from it seems to have
been leaked people suspect that there's
some type of mystery project maybe it's
a movie it might be called guava Island
the Atlanta director Hyrum RI apparently
is involved but everyone's abuzz what do
you guys think I don't know why can't
they just post like a nice photo
whenever I post a nice photo myself like
people are always commenting like oh I
wonder what his cool project is gonna be
hey man Jordan Susteren art is like he
can do anything like I'm like guys I'm
just posting a pic you're like mom and
dad you know where I am
I am annoyed by this because I'm like
yet you know with great celebrity okay
comes great like Instagram
responsibility I'm sorry but you have to
tell me information like you can't just
pose different take anymore
that's gone you need to be like
timestamp location here's the wicked
tactic cuz yeah we're talking about it
[Applause]
okay you know you're Greek josh is done
we're moving on to the next topic I want
to bring up something nice we had a we
had a long week let's talk about people
being nice out there this is called the
hash tag tip the bill challenge we have
a photo from Instagram user misc uribe
Bay and it's pretty simple you take what
the total bill was at the restaurant and
then you tip that amount so you're given
a hundred percent tip hey look bacon
Street I noticed that two bacon strange
that's funny
it sounds delicious are any of you guys
gonna practice absolutely not am I gonna
do this another chance I tip my 20% how
about the restaurant pays these people a
living well yeah why don't why is this
on me I don't care if it's nice I agree
you like nice things
like nice things why'd why do I have to
be the one that's nice all the time yes
at the end of every meal I get I have to
like decide whether I'm a generous
person in front of my friends and then -
yeah no that's you really aren't doing
math cuz you just write whatever the
bill - no not this but like just nothing
in general any tipping I think it's a
disgusting practice that I love doing
just pay waiters a normal wage this is
weird cuz I heard tip tip drill
challenge so I've been swiping credit
cards through my own butt cheeks for the
last four weeks I've been on the other
end of this so I was a waiter in high
school it was a sixteen dollar bill and
I got $20 whoa well you're a good waiter
[Music]
someone right hashtag tip challenge and
then you were like oh they're just doing
this for their own Instagram account and
I'm
and also what is Instagram I'm just
going down with tip regular definitely
take the extra copy see if you can match
Chris's tip drill challenge and see if
you can do something so this is from our
episode where we talked about urinals in
France and I mentioned in the episode I
was like okay we're letting men pee
everywhere but we're still weird about
breastfeeding and crooks adore followed
up in the comments was like actually
they're pretty cool about that in France
and I responded crooks adore you're
right France is much better when it
comes to that and he then had a lovely
response which was like really
thoughtful and thorough that I'll read a
little bit of but basically it's like I
don't know if it's really a better or
worse thing though so much as they get
less worked up about breasts in America
in general so does almost everyone
really but I think it's a lot less of a
big deal in countries where women are
commonly topless on beaches and like a
good point
that he says my suggestive opinion is
being cool the human body is a good
thing anyways I just thought I was like
thank you Chris adore for like elevating
the discussion and our YouTube comments
like delighted to have a genuine just
cruised or thank you so much for all
your thoughtful responses generally
about the show and for your responses
saying I shouldn't be on the show at all
Jordan's mortal enemy about him last
night at a show and it worked really
well so hey to our number one fan Kirk
sitar thank you for this we're gonna do
something else hello I'm Jordan and once
a week I'd take a little more
psychedelics than usual and write in my
journal these are my thoughts
if you're having trouble sympathizing
with Kanye West put yourself in his
shoes
Easy's will run you about $250 but
they're stylish comfortable and you'll
turn heads on the street also Kanye
makes beautiful music most of us here
for free and he suffers from mental
health problems so keep this all in mind
this has been hi I'm Hannah Dickinson
and this is cheers to you where I'm
kicking off my first round of the
weekend by cheering all the people and
stories that encouraged me to drink
cheer see you Chloe grace Moretz for
opening up about how you felt pressured
to get breast implants at 16 years old
I'm with you girl I felt that pressure
when I was 16 and 17 and 18 in 19 and 20
and 21 and it's not important how old I
am it's important to know you don't need
plastic surgery you just need to eat
something
cheers to you Dane Cook for dating a
girl who's 26 years younger than you I
had no idea you still had money cheers
to you Kanye West for saying in your new
song you'd smash your wife's sisters how
dare you disrespect him like that after
all the work she's had done for you
cheers to you six year old girl who
secretly ordered 350 dollars of toys off
Amazon
now that is feminism why should this
girl behave all year-round so that a man
could
once a year when she can be a bad bitch
all the time and hit up homegirl LexA
24/7
is it bad I called a six-year-old a
little bitch cheers to you man who stole
$100,000 worth of ramen noodles and got
away with it way to pull off a robbery
and still have to eat like a poor person
cheers to you the Meg for topping the
box-office last weekend I guess you're
the only movie laptop movie pass I will
go see a documentary about anal
bleaching before I pay sixteen fifty for
an actual movie Cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
you know sometimes I say hey roll that
clip and this is a if you had to fire
one of us who would it be
B gladly into what are they just Mike
thanks we'll see you next time on
everyday I'm dead you looked at me in
the eyes
[Music]